the first thing that we all expect is to
have a clear decision about the
participation of Ukraine when how under
what conditions so this is something
which is expected to be a final outcome
of this Summit another topic for
discussion are the so-called Regional
plans for the first time after the Cold
War
something that will prepare the Eastern
flank even better than than before then
Bulgaria is part of this effort so for
us this is also very important so these
are the two key topics and also the the
general context in the world how the
risks are evolving will be also a topic
for discussion you have certainly backed
Ukraine joining NATO but not until after
the war is over
um Can Ukraine
um enjoy your support long term
yes this is for sure actually we were
among the first countries that sent
direct support to Ukraine including
Military Support with ammunitions on the
other hand we accepted tens of thousands
of ukrainians on our territory and help
them to
survive in the first days and to
integrate after that so we have all the
political commitment with the decisions
of the parliament of the Council of
ministers that will continue with this
support
we have just started the preparation of
the second package of military a to
Ukraine so yes we'll continue to support
Ukraine as as long as as needed and as
you said we had a an official
declaration signed by Mr zelenski and
myself that we support their full
participation in NATO whenever it is
possible
do you support the US sending cluster
bombs to Ukraine
well this is quite a military type of
question and I'm not a military person
so after your previous uh guest I'll not
like to go deeper into this topic it's
not my my topic in fact
be a political question well it's a
political decision whether or not to use
cluster bombs you've heard the British
prime minister has said that we will not
be getting involved
yes uh politically it's a sensitive
issue because many of the countries have
signed this treaty well you know the
United States and Russia has not signed
it have not signed it so the fact that
Russia has not signed it means that they
accept that this could be a type of
ammunition that can be used there as far
as I heard they have already used such
type of ammunition so if they use them
it is a normal normal expectation that
the other side could also use them so it
is a military question whether this
creates a risk for the Ukrainian forces
this is something that I don't know how
this this will affect the the
the battles in the next days and weeks
yeah okay you've only just taken over of
course haven't you um as prime minister
uh just remind me does um does your
country has have you all are you a
signatory to Banning cluster bombs
uh yes so we have done the cluster bombs
and that's why uh we we consider this as
a military decision this is not a
political decision on our side but we
are in a full-fledged War so when you
have a world that treaties are important
but it is even more important to have a
success on the battlefield yeah with
respect Mr Prime Minister a survey last
year found 70 percent of belarussians
don't support sending weapons
um to Ukraine as a similar number uh
percentage for bulgarians
um obviously that then becomes a
political issue doesn't it
is a political issue but our assessment
of this situation is that it is
it is a result of very aggressive I
could say hybrid attacks in the media
including uh
the the services of Russia that want to
present the Russian Viewpoint of these
events and if we have a weakness from
this Viewpoint it is that we have not
explained sufficiently to our population
what really is going on what are the
risks for Bulgaria and what are the
decisions that depend on Bulgaria to
counterfeit this risk so this is what we
have to do better as you probably know
we are a little bit more than a month in
office so in the previous two years most
of the time
we had another government that was quite
soft I could say with respect to the
Russian hybrid attacks and there is
quite a a big exposure in the in the
Bulgarian media of these alternative
viewpoints some of them quite often
contradicting the facts and this is
something that we should work hard in
the next weeks and months to explain
better to our population what we have to
do okay
um Mr Prime Minister it's a pleasure
thank you so much for taking the time